how often would you say a screenwriters
first draft is their final draft never
but it brings up with I think an
important point which is that the
tendency for many writers is to think
that because writing is rewriting it's a
classic phrase that everybody says they
take the approach that go ahead and
write the first draft make mistakes feel
free to make mistakes because you can
fix it later this is a very dangerous
approach and one of that seems to be a
good idea at the time but as actually
the makings of a disaster and the reason
for that is that it means that the
writer is not doing their structural
work upfront their preparation in any
craft before you actually execute that
art form you need to do the prep work
upfront in story it is figuring out the
structure this is what I was talking
about on a television staff you don't
get to write the first draft of the
script until every story beat is figured
out in my new detail and the show under
signs off on that that's because they
know on television from experience
working under tremendous time pressure
that a lot of times most of the time it
doesn't get fixed and rewrite whatever
big structural mistakes you make in the
opening draft are then much more
difficult to fix and I use the metaphor
of concrete when you write that first
draft of the script that script that
story hardens into concrete in your mind
and now it's much more difficult to go
back into it break up that concrete
and make the kind of major structural
fixes that will give you a better script
that's the kind of work you want to do
before you write it as a script and
that's why I put so much emphasis on
doing your character work doing your
plot work especially emphasizing the 22
building blocks because that gives you
this sequence of your story before you
write it into a script and one last
point about this when I do story
consulting I would much prefer but that
someone not send me the screenplay that
they send me the scene list the sequence
essentially in the 3x5 cards because I
can much more quickly figure out what's
wrong with the story
when it's simply in the scene list that
I can when it's embedded in that
concrete in the actual script and
there's all this this undergrowth this
brush that is hiding what's really wrong
in all this dialogue I don't need that
dialogue I just need to know the stories
everything comes from making that story
work and that you've got to figure out
up front before it goes to script
you